I emailed you because I was I'm I'm from
a secular family. So
>> So what happened?
>> So like I don't know much about Judaism
in general.
>> Okay.
>> Um so I was looking into like becoming
more religious.
>> Okay.
>> And I just wanted to understand as a as
a Jew, why do I need Christianity? Why
do I need the New Testament?
uh because if you believe the Old
Testament prophesied the Messiah then
there is no Judaism without belief in
Messiah. In fact, one of the 13 articles
of faith by Moses Mymanities is that you
must affirm the Messiah. So Christianity
says your Messiah came. So if he has
come and you reject him, then you're
rejecting God.
>> And how do I know Jesus is the Messiah?
>> Well, that's what you have to examine,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> So you have to examine the claims of
Jesus and his followers. see if they're
anchored in the Old Testament and the
interpretation of the Old Testament is
correct.
>> But like from what I understand, it's
only like shown in Isaiah. Like
>> it's only in Isaiah. No, it's not. Even
the rabbis point to many passages in the
Hebrew scriptures. Rabbis not Christians
say this is messianic. For example,
Daniel 7:13-14
where the prophet Daniel has a vision of
the son of man coming in the clouds of
heaven. you have in the tomud and rash
himself saying this is king Messiah and
that's a passage that Jesus himself
quoted in reference to himself. So a lot
of the prophecies found in the New
Testament where they say this passage is
about Messiah Psalm 27
Daniel 7:13-14
Daniel 9 even the rabbis agree it's
Messiah though they reject Jesus.
Okay. So it's just not Jesus but
>> yeah they'll say it's Messiah but they
don't believe it's Jesus. But that's the
dilemma for them. For example Daniel 9
Rashi himself says that the timet given
in Daniel 9 Daniel 2 shows that the
messianic kingdom had to be established
during the time when Titus who is the
general of the Roman armies who came and
destroyed the second temple. In 66 to 73
AD you had what's called the Jewish war.
when the Jews opposed the Roman
occupation and then the emperor sent an
army headed by Titus to then bank
Jerusalem locking the Jews in Jerusalem
causing a great famine where even an
historian said the woman started eating
their children because of the famine.
Then they came in destroyed the temple
burned it down.
Rashi says that according to Daniel, it
was during that time that the messianic
kingdom had to be established. So he
admits that Daniel's timetable says
Messiah was to show up and establish the
kingdom during that time.
>> Well, where is the Messiah? I'm going to
show you
>> after the Barabar revolt.
>> No, that's in the second century. You're
talking about in 130s. I'm talking about
66 to 73 AD.
Rashi says the messianic kingdom was
supposed to establish at that time. So
where's the Messiah? Because he's saying
that's the timet given by Daniel here.
Show it to you. So where is he?
>> I don't know. I don't
>> exactly because when the Jews rejected
Jesus, not all of them, the first
believers were Jews. They were not
Gentiles. When they rejected Jesus, they
didn't know what to do with the
prophecy. So they had to reinterpret
them. Here it is. Let me show it to you.
Here it is.
Okay. Right here. I'm going to show it
to you on the screen. I just put in a
private chat. Here it is. And here my
article. But then I'm going to go online
and show you. Watch here. So what does
he say here? He's talking about Daniel
9:24 to 27. 70 weeks decreed. He says
here, this is him. It says so that
Israel should receive their retribution,
the exile of Titus and subjugation. So
he's saying when Titus destroyed
Jerusalem, this is when Israel received
their retribution. All right? Now, so
you can see that I'm not making up. He
says that the anointed one because in
Nan talks about Mashiach Nag the
anointed one, the ruler would be cut
off. He says it was Agria who was killed
in in around 40 AD 10 years after Jesus.
But why Agrippa?
Why did he say it's him? Why didn't he
say it's Jesus? And he says Titus and
his armies would come and destroy the
temple. But then he says and his end
will come about by inundation and his
end will be damnation and destruction
for he will unend inundate the power of
his kingdom through the Messiah. So he's
saying that during this time
you would have the messianic era, the
messianic kingdom. And he's placing it
in that period of time when Jesus
walked, was killed, was buried, and his
followers claim that he rose from the
dead and ascended to heaven. But then he
doesn't admit it's Jesus.
Let me get you the link.
>> So who is it if it's not Jesus?
>> That's that's what you got to tell them.
But that's why so many Jews end up
becoming followers of Jesus because
these are prophecies. So you got to tell
to saying hey Tovia who where's the
Messiah? What do you mean? Rashi says
according to Daniel 9 timet
the messianic kingdom had to have
started at that era an anointed one a
ruler anointed messianic figure would be
cut off. Why didn't I link to kabad.org?
Am I stupid? Hold on. I'm supposed to
link to it in my article but I'll show
it to you online.
>> Thank you.
>> Sometimes I'm stupid. I think I link to
stuff and I don't. said, "I got to go
update my article." What the hell?
Anyway, let me go here. Kabad.org.
Here it is. I'll get you the link. See
how stupid I am, man. I even All right.
Uh, text writings. Sorry, that happens.
All right. So, these are some of the
many prophecies that Christians point to
in the Hebrew scriptures. And even the
rabbis admit here is kabad.org. This is
their Bible translation. Washi com. I'm
going to put it in the I'm going to put
it in here. You see the private chat?
>> Yeah.
>> I just sent you the link and for
everyone else. All right. So, Messiah
was supposed to show up at that time.
Okay. Where is he?
Well, if you reject Jesus, Daniel's a
false prophet because his prophecy says
Messianic Kingdom Messiah would start at
that time. Well,
Jesus came and went. The temple was
destroyed.
Jews say, "Well, he's not the Messiah.
So, is Daniel a false prophet?"
Obviously not. So, here, let me now show
it to you. We're going to go here.
We go to Ketuim.
We go to Daniel.
All right. Now, we go to Daniel 9. Boom.
We click here.
Okay. Then, we we show show and then we
put word Messiah. Here it is to
terminate to the transgression and to
end sin. So that Israel should receive
their complete retribution and exile of
Titus and his subjugation order that
their transgression should terminate,
their sins should end, and their
iniquities should be expedated in order
to bring upon them eternal righteousness
to anoint upon them the holy of holies,
the ark, the altars, the holy vessels
which they will bring to them through
the king Messiah. So this is all going
to happen through the king Messiah when
Titus comes to destroy the temple in
Jerusalem 70 AD. Well 70 AD came and
went. Where's the Messiah?
>> So like what's what's the objection?
Like what's the Jewish objection?
>> I don't know why they rejected Jesus.
Why do they continue to do so? Here and
a Zen will come about by inundation.
And a Zen will be damnation and
destruction for you'll inundate the
power of kingdom through the Messiah.
And it's all talking about Jerusalem and
temple being destroyed in 70 AD. And it
says this happens through the Messiah.
What Messiah? You don't believe Jesus
the Messiah. So where is he now? Watch.
And until destruction, extermination
befall the dumb one. And the ruling of
the abomination will endure until the
day that the destruction and termination
decreed upon it will befall in the days
of the king Messiah.
Okay. Well, 70 AD came and went, buddy.
Where is the Messiah? I don't know what
to tell you.
>> All right. Um, so and what about like
all the tradition like Jewish tradition
about like the Messiah bringing like
world peace and stuff? Is that not
biblical or
>> Well, that's the thing. They don't tell
you that the Hebrew Bible mentions a
Messiah that will be killed and be
resurrected and then the Messiah who
comes to resurrect him. Are you aware in
the Babylonian to have messiahs?
They have what?
>> Two messiahs.
>> Yeah, I know about that tradition. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, you're aware of Mashiach Ben
Ysef. Mashia.
>> Yeah.
Right.
>> Excuse me.
>> Mashia Mashiach Ben Ysef is killed,
right?
>> I don't know.
>> Yeah. Two Messiahs. Mashiach Ben Yosf
will be killed in battle and Mashiach
Ben Davided who will resurrect him.
>> Okay.
>> That's an atonement. But wait, where did
they get a Messiah son of Joseph who
will be killed? Because I thought the
Christians are lying when they say the
Messiah must be killed.
But in the tots Messiah, son of Joseph,
will be killed according to Zechariah
12:10.
Here, let me show you.
>> Somebody's laughing at me that I don't
know Judaism and I'm a Jew.
>> Who cares? Don't ignore them, dude.
Whoever says that, I'll block them.
You think they're Christians who know
their Bible, guys?
Do you think they're Christians?
that know their Bible. Why would you
laugh that Jews don't know their own
tradition? He just told you he's a
secular Jew. Come on. Did you know your
faith before you came here? Zechariah,
let's see. 12:10. Watch here. 12:10. You
ready? Now, even though I don't agree
with his the way he translates the
Hebrew, but that's okay. Zechariah
12:10. If you read Hebrew, you're going
to see it says, "They shall look on me
whom they pierce. Not they shall look on
me about the ones who were slain." But
here, Zechariah 12:10, "And I will part
upon the house of David, upon the habit
of Jerusalem, a spirit of grace and
supplications. They shall look to me
because of those who have been thrust
through." There is no plural. If you
read the Hebrew, I don't know if you
can. It says they should look. Can you?
>> Yeah. Can you show me the Hebrew?
>> Read it for me.
>> Little loudly.
Okay.
What?
Translate that.
>> Stabbed or pierced?
>> Uh, they
>> they stabbed and pierced. Who?
>> Yeah. Uh,
I don't know.
>> Reread it again. They should look on me.
Eli
>> whom they pierced.
>> They pierced who?
>> That a is the object marker. meaning the
ones who pierced
me.
Read it carefully.
>> But means on him.
>> Yes. No, that's now the next line. And
they will mourn for him.
>> Oh, I love
>> But it's still singular.
>> Yeah,
>> it's still singular. It's not them.
>> Yeah, it's singular.
>> But why did they translate it as plural
here? Look at the English.
And
>> they shall look to me because of those
whom who've been thrust through.
>> No, it's singular.
>> You got it. So that means you just admit
here are the rabbis or the Jews that
mistransated the Hebrew.
>> Why did they do that? They accuse us of
mistransating.
Right now here, who is it though? Who
was the one that they killed? Here you
go. Rashi right here. As one mourns over
an only son, as a man mourns over his
only son and our sages expounded this in
tractate
as referring to the Messiah, son of
Joseph who was slain. So rabbitic
Judaism admits the Messiah will be
killed.
>> But I thought Jesus is son of like
Mashiach.
>> I'm not telling you the rabbis are right
because where does it say this Messiah
is a son of Joseph? What I'm trying to
show you is the rabbis admit there's a
Messiah who will be killed
>> here. Read in Hebrew. Read it for us.
killed to be killed.
>> Who's going to be killed?
>> Uh the Messiah. The
>> But I thought you the rabbis say we
Christians are lying that in the Hebrew
Bible Messiah is killed.
>> Oh no. Kabad says that he will be
killed.
>> And Kabad is not quoting Kabad. It's
quoting Rashi. This is Rashi's
commentary. And Rashi said this is what
our sages taught.
>> Okay. So my question to the Jews is why
do you accuse Christians of butchering
the Old Testament, misquing it, that
there's nowhere in the Hebrew Bible that
Messiah will be killed? Your rabbis say
Messiah will be killed. Zechariah 12:10,
which is what we quote. John quotes this
about Jesus being killed on the cross.
>> Here, let me show you. You see the
Zechariah 12:10.
You just read that the rabbis admit this
is about Messiah, but they say Mashiach
Ben Yoseseph, right?
>> Yeah, they do.
>> Right.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Now, watch John saying this is
about Messiah and Jesus fulfilled it.
Watch. Same verse. Now, we're going to
go here.
Okay. John
19 30- 37. much. So why do the rabbis
then say the New Testament's making
things up? How are we making it up? Your
rabbi said, "Yeah, this passage is about
Messiah." And John said, "Yep." And
Jesus is a Messiah. And when he was
pierced on the cross, he fulfilled it.
Here, therefore, when Jesus had received
the sour wine, he said, "It is
finished." And bowing his head, he gave
up his spirit. Then the Jews, because it
was a day of preparation, so that the
bodies would not remain on the cross on
the Sabbath, for that Sabbath was a high
day, asked Pilate that their legs might
be broken, and that they might be taken
away. So the soldiers came, broke the
legs of the first man, and of the other
was crucified with him. But coming to
Jesus, when they saw that he was already
dead, they did not break his legs. But
one of the soldiers pierced his side.
Pierced Jesus side with a spear.
There's that word. And immediately blood
and water came out. And he who has seen
has borne witness. And his witness is
true, saying, "See, I'm an eyewitness. I
was there. I'm writing as an eyewitness.
And he knows that he's telling the truth
so that you also may believe. For these
things came to pass in order that the
scripture might be fulfilled. Not a bone
of him shall be broken. And notice here
and again another scripture. They shall
look on him whom they pierced.
That's Zechariah 12:10.
So why is it when the Christian quotes
Zechariah 12:10 saying, "See when Jesus
was killed on the cross and pierced, he
fulfilled Zechariah 12:10. No baloney.
Messiah is not killed. But then that's
what the rabbi said. They agreed with
us. They agreed with John the Jew that
Zechariah 12:10 is about Messiah.
>> I see
>> right here.
>> What if like Rashi is just wrong? Like
>> but he said the sages, not him.
>> Sages plural. They're all wrong. Then
who got it right?
>> Yeah.
Okay. So, this is what happens when we
follow people like anti-Christian rabbi
Tovia Singer. They don't tell you these
facts. They only try to show we're
wrong. But then we go and read their
sources. But wait, wait, wait, hold on,
Tovia. You told me nowhere in the Old
Testament, Hebrew scriptures, Tanakh,
there's a Messiah will be killed. What
about Zechariah 12:10? the Tmud, your
rabbis say, "This is Messiah, son of
Joseph, who's killed." So that means
we're right. There is a Messiah will be
killed.
But you're denying it's Jesus. Then who
is it?